you absolutely can sell something for a
million dollars if you go to an
e-commerce store and they're doing a
hundred million dollars a year and you
say hey if I can increase your
conversion across your entire site
rewrite your emails redo your landing
pages Etc and I can get you a five
percent lift site-wide can I get one
percent of that so you make them an
extra five million a year and you get
one and you're like I don't know how to
do that that's fine but accept that you
don't know how to do that and then say I
want to learn how to do that and then go
get the skill of doing that and then you
can go sell it you can't say that you
don't have the money and that's why you
can't make money that's how you make a
million dollars like real talk